welcome back well illegal border
crossings break a new record with CBP
reporting over 300,000 Encounters in
December the highest month ever recorded
yeah and our next guest outlines in a
new opad how it could be impacting your
wallet Todd binman is a senior fellow at
the center for immigration studies and
he joins us now Todd tell us how this
crisis which is a crisis that has been
acknowledged almost by everyone except
for the president the United States
affects everyone's
wallet well for one thing they're not
just coming here on their own dime uh
the United Nations it turns out is
spending hundreds of millions of dollars
in cash handouts food shelter something
called humanitarian
Transportation uh really every human
need that uh is required to make the
long journey through uh Latin
America Central America and
Mexico uh and who pays the UN who who's
the un's major funder it's the US
taxpayer is paying for this uh how do we
know this because there's a brand new
budget document that the UN puts out uh
for 2024 they're going to spend $1.6
billion to help 3 Mill illegal
immigrants uh move through 17 different
countries of Latin America and the
cariban and Mexico and that includes
$370 million in cash cards debit cards
uh $25 million in transportation
assistance to help them move through and
the budget document also
clearly uh shows that they are witting
that they they know that these are
illegal immigrants and that they are
moving illegally through their own
member states and they're using
248 NOS to help hand out the cash so so
go ahead well Todd I was going to say
first of all the UN is 0 for two for
with us this morning uh but this money
is supposed to go to legitimate Asylum
Seekers what's the vetting process
like uh that's a a big mystery but uh
you know I've been down at the border
I've I've been to these waste stations
uh I've interviewed the um illegal
immigrants who are receiving this I've
had them take show me their their debit
cards the whole thing they they say that
it's for the most vulnerable uh but you
know there's they're planning to hand
out debit cards and cash equivalents to
624 th000 illegal immigrants in
2024 none of them look particularly
vulnerable able to me uh I mean a lot of
them are grown men they're adults uh
they don't seem weak or or sick or
anything like that um they they they say
it's for the most vulnerable but I I
don't see it I'm sure there are some
vulnerable people that are that are
receiving this Cash Aid but I also think
that they just want to help as many
illegal immigrants as possible move to
the United States and they know it and
they say it in the budget document which
is Linked In My New York uh post and the
center for immigration studies piece
that I that I uh published on this
matter I think you're exactly right
there's an agenda there so just to be
clear for our audience we're funding the
UN the UN is funding people in Central
America who they deem to be vulnerable
even if they're not vulnerable to make
the trk to the United States with our
taxpayer
dollars there's a little bit of irony
there uh yes and some Republicans have
have been angry about this uh ever since
it it was revealed that we're just
handing out all this cash along the way
uh that our our United Nations is doing
this look a lot of the money is
earmarked by the White House by the
state
department uh and go goes straight to uh
the United Nations High Commission on
refugees
uncr and theom the um uh International
Organization for migration that's who's
that's the pass through but there's 15
other un agencies uh that are involved
as well wow well Todd thanks for doing
the the Spade work on this we're dig in
even more scary thank you thank you Todd
I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian kilme and I'm
Angley aart and click here to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page to catch
our hottest interviews and most
compelling
analysis